Well, that's my journey. That's your
journey. And wherever the spirit leads
you, Amen. Submit. Amen. Right. And if I
may ask, good. Until now, what's your
what's the church where you you believe
until now is the most like is what what
you're saying have has all the dollar or
maybe most of it. I have to say my
experience, this is my experience. And I
know it's going to shock somebody
because I'm at the Church of the East.
Church of the East because I wanted to
give it a a chance because it's the
church of my ancestors. I've been
immensely impressed. I know it's going
to shock someone. Please don't get
offended and stone me. I've been
immensely impressed with Roman
Catholics. I have seen a variety of
Roman Catholics and I've seen the love
and the passion and the grace and the
charity among them and it's moved my
heart. One of the most loving servants
of the Lord that I met is Father Richard
Simon. He has a radio show called uh
Father Knows Best. I used to go to his
Bible studies and I've met some of the
most godly people, godly
women in the Catholic church by divine
appointment, godly women coming up to me
telling me
stuff, just signs from the Lord. and
they happen to be devout Catholic women
who prayed the rosary
devoutly. That's my experience. It's
even been see it's moving me in my
heart. So that's that's what it is. So
and this is coming from someone who's in
the church of the east. The love I have
seen among the Catholics, it's it's
humbling. Not saying I haven't seen love
than others. I I've encountered more
Catholics by divine appointment. I'm
talking about divine appointment. God
appointing me to run into Catholics more
so than even Assyrians from the Church
of the East and even more than the
Orthodox. I can give you a miracle if
you want to hear it if you have time.
It's up to you. For sure. Yes. A divine
appointment. A divine appointment from
the Lord. Uh this was the first
November. Unfortunately, I have to bring
this up. People going to they tell me,
"Stop talking about your ex. I'm not
talking about her because I want to talk
about her. There's situations where I
have to bring her up." Sad.
Unfortunately for her, she didn't think
about the ramifications because I'm in
public minister. I'm a public figure.
Things like this come up that November
where the
judge ruled that I could not stay in the
house because my ex-wife and the lawyers
used the corrupt legal system to get me
out of the
home in order to bring her boyfriend
into the house. It was November.
Thanksgiving was around the corner. I
had to spend that Thanksgiving. It was
November 2017. And I know some of these
sisters, in fact, they may be listening.
I hope they're listening as a witness.
She are you here? Moren, are you
listening? Martin. Martin, your aunts.
Martin's here. Your aunts were there.
They were there for this miracle. She
was there. Moren was there. Patty was
there. And Michelle, they actually
listened to my program. They're probably
listening now. Martin's aunts. Two of
them. They're sisters. Anyway, it was it
was Thanksgiving. I didn't know where to
go. I thought there was a Persian
restaurant that was going to open up
that was going to be open on
Thanksgiving. So, we're going to go
there, me and these sisters, cuz even
these poor sisters also come from broken
families. Anyway, older sisters, some of
them are old enough to be my mother. But
anyway, we found out it's
closed. So, then the only place open was
an IHOP. IHOP breakfast joint. Now
remember, it's
Thanksgiving virtually. It's empty. We
go there. I get there before the sisters
do and I see a car that's parked, a
white car, small car. I get out. Two
ladies get out. Older ladies. One lady
was probably in her 60s. The other one
in her 70s. They get out, too. Now,
watch this story, guys. True story. I
think I was going to Panera Bread.
That's what it was. Not the Persian
restaurant. Either way, we ended up in
IHOP. True story, guys. They're my
witnesses if I'm lying. They're my
witnesses if I'm lying to you. We go
into IHOP. We sit in a table. These two
ladies are sitting not too far from me.
Sisters show up. So, we decide now to go
to the back of the room, the the
breakfast joint. We're talking about my
issue. We're talking about what my
ex-wife is doing and her affair. And
we're talking about Jesus. All of a
sudden, about an hour after the
conversation, those two ladies stand to
my right. So, like, imagine me, I'm
sitting. They're here. I turn. I go like
this. I'm like, "What's going on?" So,
they look at me. The younger of the two
says, "You know what?" She's got a
smile. We were not listening, but we
were listening. Another she's saying,
"We're pretending not to be listening to
you, but we couldn't help it." Hear what
you said, "Brother, listen to this.
Listen to this miracle." She
goes, "The things you were saying about
Jesus, oh my
goodness, you blew us away."
They were hearing me talk about Jesus.
Now, here's where you're going to get
blown away. The older of the two, here's
the miracle. Here's the part of the
miracle. The older two, when I told her
my story, she said, "I'm part of a
prayer chain." I think she told me over
100,000 people on that prayer chain,
devout Catholics who pray the rosary and
we're going to be praying for you. Sign
number one. The second sign, this is
what they told me. They go, "We were not
supposed to be here. We were going to
Boston Market, but either she said it
was closed or too many people, so we had
no choice but to come here. We were not
planning to come here, but now we know
why we came. We came for you."
Wow. That's one
miracle. Okay. You want me to give you a
second miracle or am I putting you to
sleep? No, go ahead. Second miracle
that's Catholic related.
God was working on my heart and
softening me to the Catholic church. So,
unbeknownst to my Protestant brothers
and sisters, St. Lbert's, I even give
you the name of the church. It's called
St. Lbert's Church. It's in Skoi,
Illinois. So, Muslims, I don't go there
anymore and they got nothing to do with
my ministry. All right. Anyway, I'm in
another state. The beautiful thing about
Lambert's Catholic Church, it would be
open during the daytime. So, I would
secretly sneak in and I would go into
the church and I'd bow before the altar
and I would pray. I that's when I
started praying the rosary and I would
pray and ask God to show up and help me
and help my daughters.
Okay. One Sunday I decided to go and
pray. Now, I forgot that Sunday they
have mass. I forgot. So, I go there and
it's jam-packed. Like, wow, man.
Jam-packed. So, I waited for it to
finish.
As it's finishing, a young teenage boy,
maybe 16, shows up and his mother had
seen me in the Bible study that what was
it? Thursday. She didn't know who I was,
but she could tell by the way I was
asking questions that I had some
knowledge of the Bible. Now, so I
recognize the mother from that Thursday
Bible study. It's now Sunday. Her son is
there. He looks at me. God, God is my
witness. That's what I'm about to tell
you. I've shared this before. I'm going
to share it again. God is my witness. He
goes, "You're Sam Shimon, aren't you?" I
go, "How do you know?" He goes, "Man, I
follow you and David Wood." It's like,
"I can't get rid of David Wood. I'm
stuck with him."
Right? I go, I go, "You follow me?" He
goes, "Yeah, man. You and David Wood. Oh
my goodness. You're my hero. I'm about
to pass out." I go, "No, calm down. Calm
down." Now, how did he find out about
me? His best friend is a Muslim. Guys,
you want to get you want to start
crying? How real the Lord is? You want
to start crying? Okay. His best friend's
a Muslim. Because of that, he went
looking for answers online. He found me
and he found David Wood and started
learning from us and witnessing to his
Muslim friend. Now, as he's sharing the
story, he goes, "Please, can I bring my
Muslim friend? He's not too far from
here. He knows about you and I want him
to meet you." I go, "Sure." Now, part of
the miracle he told me, "I wasn't coming
to mass today. I didn't feel like it,
but I felt something putting in my heart
to come. Now I know why. Because I was
going to see you." Now, before I get to
the story with his Muslim friend, his
mother looks at me, goes, "Now I know
why you know so much about the Bible."
Because, you know, she figured out from
the conversation. Look what she tells
me. Miracle number two with the rosary.
Miracle number two. She goes, "I'm part
of a group of women that have devoted
ourselves to praying the rosary as
intercessors. I mean intercessor
intercessor. I pray and intercede. Every
Monday we gather and we intercede. You
will now be included in my list of
people intercede for with these other
sisters who pray the rosary, intercede
for people." Second time, notice who
again is doing it. Catholics, right?
Mhm. But now watch the story with the
young Muslim lad. The boy comes back. I
meet the Muslim lad. Within 20 minutes I
answer his
objections. And then we have another
meeting. The second meeting he basically
said, he goes, "Now I have no objections
against the Trinity and I do believe
Jesus is God." A young 16-year-old boy
Muslim boy said, "I'm about getting
moved in my spirit."
a young Muslim
boy whom this young Catholic boy was
witnessing to. And the Lord had brought
him to the YouTube channel to find me
because God had planned this ages ago
that Sam Schum would show up at that
young boy church, Catholic church, and
be used to bring his Muslim friend to
Christ.
And you want you want me to believe the
Catholic Church is not a church loved by
the
Lord. See what the Lord's doing. That's
just too many. Amen. Anyway, man, I'm
sorry you're getting me emotional. Big
big boys are not supposed to
cry. No, no, it's amazing stories. If
you have go if you have other questions